all right this is Frost and fire mixed
emotions on this one because on the one
hand I really really liked this episode
like a lot like the comedy is so good
this I think is hilarious the delivery
is great um but Finn's really a dick in
this oh my god why you're not perverts
okay let's go over the story here so a
Finn and Flame Princess that they're out
having a picnic um Flame Princess a fool
over to me it was that was that just me
it jumped a little taller okay um but
and then Ice King flies by just kind of
making fun of them so Flame Princess
goes just beat the living sin out of him
and Finn has this dream later that night
where she's setting him on fire he likes
it his crotch is crushed specifically on
fire and he likes it so much that he
wants the dream again so he tries to
force Flame Princess and Ice King to
fight again and pretty much does that
coax her into doing it trying to see a
fight where there wasn't and he has the
dream again that night except this time
it's the Ice King freezing his junk and
except this time there's the cosmic owl
so Jake says oh my god the cosmic cow
cosmic owl is saying you have to have
them fight again because that could be a
dream that's gonna predict the future or
something and so he makes up these two
letters you know trying to force them to
fight they have this great big I mean
just epically funny battle I mean that
was just hugely funny uh I mean you
heard me life not allowed several times
I mean like I said just that the speed
and the slapstick in the lines they're
saying I mean it's just so funny uh but
then it gets a little too far and Finn
passes out and has a dream we're good
god he's in bed his junks on fire and
then like it goes too far where she's
almost wasting away and they turns into
this little grown-up baby thing just
going wah wah wah wah wah and she turns
around and
leaves and then the cosmic owl says you
blew it uh and then that's pretty much
what happens if she finds out the fights
were being forced you know that he made
them up and he said some - yeah her
credit some really mean harsh things you
know that only he would know what to get
them to fight and she says she needs
time to think about if she walks off and
the Ice King says yeah blow it um so
yeah like I said on the one hand
majority of this episode I thought was
really well-written it really funny and
uh um movie what okay so so it's really
funny you know I'm really well-written
and everything and the slapstick as
grain the animation is great the voice
acting is great but yeah I don't know
about finding this one I'm just like I
mean I don't know just the idea of I
mean I guess I know he's still young and
everything but the idea of getting two
people to fight I mean like really
invoking violence where it's not needed
on someone that okay it's not purely
innocent but you you know is for the
most part not doing anything wrong and
then causing such anger and you know
hate from both of them and it causing
this very violence of just so he can get
a dream maybe he likes uh I don't know I
thought the only one I was kind of a
little bit more I can understand a touch
more was the last one because it might
be a dream that means something is gonna
come true or whatever um I don't know
about that crap even then I'm like you
know what just leave it you know even if
it's like oh that could mean something
or made it just leave it it's gonna
happen you know one way or another a
does happen you know it's a
self-fulfilling prophecy so I'm always
like leave that crap you know don't go
to fortune tellers they're they're fake
anyway but even if they weren't it's I
do why would you want to knowing ruins
the surprise okay Eve looks like you
know 25 percent of your viewing people
believed it and no longer the glass
fortune tellers they would have known
yes so so yes it's like I love
everything about it except except then
in this one because I really did feel it
was like I said I can see another Dumber
character doing these character I can
see no no I could see Jake doing this no
affair because he's so stupid but I
really can't see Finn especially for
someone you know his hands or the
heartbreak with bubblegum and then like
Flame Princess seems really cool and
again you know couples sometimes they're
gonna go too far and they're gonna have
you something but this is he like it was
really really abusing it and going
against you know what sir what he
believes as a hero and stuff like that
so it's it's really not it that's like
the one element but it's a kind of a big
element so yeah like I really liked oh
I'm glad I saw it I thought was really
funny and and the dreams were cool and
everything I just I don't like I don't
think I like Finn in it it's yeah I
agree with you I like it it's a good
episode but Finn is the biggest prick
ever like what a jerk and a half I mean
he puts bubblegum to shame like what a
jerk and unbelievable unbelievably so to
the point where my first well after my
first like half a second reaction if oh
no they broke up it's like yeah good for
her because if they kept them together
and somehow made it work no that would
yes I so many I was ill to see how they
could do that respecting person would
walk away and say no that's not okay
I mean people make mistakes but she said
it right and they liked even the voice
actress the yen and everything she you
know it was just very simple but she
still got the point across very well she
said those were some very personal
things that only you would know and the
first thing that popped in my head I was
like yeah and he
something about you know you can't even
kiss Finn without freaking amenities
like manually harsh young like young and
I'm thinking to myself you know okay
sometimes a character has to go outside
of a comfort zone or for them to be
interesting to saying that surprises you
but it's like that was just it just
didn't seem like him it's just for him
to say something else just so me and
it's so hateful and so you know it just
for a dream that granted you know oh
well I die in this or not but it's like
I can't see him doing that not to
somebody that he cares so much about and
honestly I was just so focused on the
fact that oh my god fire-crotch
somebody's working out some sexual
issues with this episode like well I
guess you know no no I don't agree not
for anything for the dream what kind of
sick of mind are you like oh my crotch
was on fire I'd like that again let's
make things happen
Jason you look like you have a story no
nothing so what do you think I'm not
seeing anything no I I liked it um to an
extent hey I get why why everyone is
upset with Finn but at the same time the
way I'm looking at it is he's 14 I think
at this point in time and he's 14 so I
don't know yeah but orchestrate this
whole big thing orchestrate how over sit
here when Ice King comes by a minute
just say oh no no he's treating you like
crap okay okay that's not that bad oh
the other one no well yeah I hate him
wait did that when he started writing
how was he reacting Jake starts flipping
out yelling at him and he's not thank
you I you need to have this happen
because this is important and finna runs
and he's like blah and he's just
flipping out while he's writing does it
excuse what he writes no but I think at
the same time that's the reason why he
such hateful things he needed it to
escalate to that level in order of room
to feel something
I guess okay I guess my point is this is
that why even bother get them to fight
again to begin with from that I mean it
was a harmless party like so what dreamy
I mean a backcountry thing but it did
escalate because he started that
escalation it was like oh I just want to
force it well happen again on the one
hand I think what you said about him
being 14 being of teenage boy and stuff
like that like I do kind of get the idea
of having it go on and even to some you
know even kept escalating because no
consequences have come from it yet and
again I do kind of understand that and
like I say it's and even if he wrote the
letter just that your feet are stinky
and blah blah blah it's like by the way
the delivery on that was very funny you
know you bigoted above abhava I see what
they were trying to do - they were
trying to really make it go by fast so
you like you don't even think about it
you know and to show like even he's not
thinking about it but I mean it was just
like and people slip up especially
14-year olds I mean it's a bit base lip
up saying stuff but it's like I you know
I don't know but maybe it's just you and
me but something about those those words
and that that was just like a really
like meant that is like a dagger in that
character I actually do agree I mean
ain't like I'm not trying to excuse him
for what he did like the words he said
were very harsh and I understand why
Flame Princess is like someone that
would be no nobody's ringtone but I mean
at the same time you mean everyone that
that age has screwed up in some way
shape or form and I don't know I kind of
look back on my past and I'm like man
when I was 14
me and my girl twin I never had a
girlfriend well
I can of it because girlfriends you
didn't have 18 I said well that's I'll
make up for the girlfriends using that
oh no I'll tell you right now I can
totally I can't you you do stupid stuff
I mean you do it's like a I mean you
already do kind of stupid stuff when
you're love anyway but it's like you do
really stupid stuff when you're young
and loved like really young um so I
guess I I definitely get that I get that
angle um even though technically it
wasn't for love per se but you know you
still do stupid things um and I like I
said I get that there was no
consequences being thrown at him so why
would me do more but yeah I guess it's
that is that choice of words I mean that
that was really the one where I'm like
yeah yeah I don't know um like I think
you could have him do or say something
else that would still get her to sort of
be like yeah I need time away I need to
be away from you and still have a fit
Vince character cut there's also a kid
that's gone E's fight like monsters and
you know he's talked about friendship a
start about relationships you know like
even the stuff with bubblegum like when
he was putting his head in her lap and
stuff like you know it was disturbing
and uncomfortable but you get it he was
yeah he was in areas like 12 or 13 or
something like that so you kind of get
it um it still seemed in character where
this one yeah it just it felt off it's
like maybe it's just that choice of
words or whatever it just felt off no oh
no one of my favorite scenes those with
the Ice King where the place is on fire
and Finn's running in to save him and
he's like see good dirt so as he's
walking over you hear asking guys King
say I meant after you save me yeah let's
go ahead and talk about a few other
really good things and because there's
so much the part where they're fight
where they're fighting and she shoots a
fireball in the area it's like ice and
then just cracks him in the face
yeah that was good I loved her dream
bigger than him turning
Mountain the game the snow and about to
turn to desires I think growing delay I
mean the speed in which it escalate but
it's still kept a large I love the ice
guy the ice golem carrying a bunch of
the Gunther I loved Finn still carrying
the Ice King at the end it's like while
he's talking to her he still has it just
the look at ice King's face like he's
just so annoyed yeah this is all Yeti
has to be carried around like it might
be that's great
yeah carry me like a princess yeah
something that you know it's maybe this
isn't the episode to bring it up I don't
know but uh you know if all the voice
actors are wonderful I think they're
really really good and I think it's a
Tom Kenny yeah yeah yeah I think he's
got like a ton of awards or something
around easy not very vague a voice actor
uh and what I realized doesn't say
myself why some voice actors and not
others who do all these various voices
and stuff and I'm realizing with
particularly with the ice cam sure as
other characters uh when he comes in and
starts talking you know like even with
some of these are voice actors are
really good it's like it's still a voice
it's it's still you know a performance
and it's fun and I believe it but when
he comes as the Ice King it's like 100%
genuine everything it's like I don't
hear a guy in a booth talking and every
inflection everything is like this is
what the character would do you know
this is you know even the little size
and the little you know hey he could
just say hey and it's like Oh Ice King
is here it's like I don't hear oh hey
Tom Kenny's doing the Ice King or hey
the character of the Ice King is
innocent no Ice King
yeah you know and there's really
something that you know that's really
hard to do to just truly engulf
something like that and I think he does
it very very well well even I think for
me too
besides that is that when he does
Simon's voice there's a difference oh
you know I was gonna say the exact same
that's one thing that I absolutely adore
about him is that it's Simon
and yes it's Ice King and yes you can
obviously tell it's his voice but there
is just a difference there's just
enough of a difference for you to get
the different characters that they are
they're two separate people they're the
same but they're separate and he just
just by the way he says things by his
voice for his inflections everything
it's completely different and that's
pretty difficult to do I mean it's easy
you're I would imagine to come up with
different sounding voices which I'm not
saying it's it's easy cuz I'm not but I
would imagine you can do a low voice and
you can do a high voice and you can do a
little girl's voice and that's kind of
cool but to do the same voice but still
have a difference for me is pretty
amazing
yes subtlety I mean and that's what he
uses very well yeah it's that he's got
the Simon voices was more human I guess
yes more human more caring more loving
if you will and then the Ice King which
is a bit more crazy and kooky non-human
sounding to the exact same but at the
same time they're completely different
opposite ends of the spectrum and he
pulls it off so well that I think if you
looked away and he came up and he was
doing like each voice switching off kind
of jumping around you probably would it
be like oh that's Simon oh that Simon
again Ice King you know I think he it's
that different and that's well done that
you'd be able to pick it up that easily
well and it's very much like even with
ice King's voice and ice King's voice
you know it's not there you know where
that top voice but like I said it's I
think that makes it in some ways even
trickier to make a connection because it
is so over-the-top and so goofy but like
I say he he's just so comfortable with
it you know it's like listening to you
know like Bugs Bunny or Daffy Duck you
know it's like you don't hear melp like
I never heard Mel Blanc doing things but
he'll I Prudential recordings I've been
going you know yeah what's up doc do it
again yeah all right yeah what's up that
it's like no that still Bugs Bunny I'm
just hearing Bugs Bunny you know there's
this guy Mel Blanc and somehow he you
know calls upon Bugs Bunny to go inside
his mouth or something you know it's
it's just one of those things where it's
like someone can just be so good and so
comfortable in a voice and in a
for months and that's definitely what I
think when it right here the ice getting
well for me it's a love um Hanuman
doesn't matter that's not where I'm
going with this we said like Mary on the
guy who did the voice of Elmo oh gosh
yeah um and there's this one scene I've
always been a huge fan of the Muppets
I've been a fan of Sesame Street I've
always like they did get me teary-eyed
just I love them that much
well there's one scene where he's
looking in a mirror with one of his
creations and he starts talking to it
and I literally I knew it was him but at
the same time it was like that's not him
talking that's that guy talking yeah
like it's kind of like that for me it's
that he's so good at his craft that even
knowing watching him do this right in
front of you I make that disconnect and
I'm like oh no separate separate you
know they're different people and a lot
of times that happens with like the Ice
King and with thin another one is
actually now Jake and Jake I was gonna
say Jake's like pretty close for me
because when I first heard his voice I
was like oh that's better yeah exactly
but now it's like I always kind of hear
Jake and like I said there is just this
very comfortable I'm sure a lot it's the
way it's written - they're both very
well ring characters but there is just
this very comfortable feeling to their
voice where they're just like no no I
know this kid I am the character it's
not that I know them that's like yeah
i'ma careful it's it's the delivery
they're not delivering their lines
they're just they're talking yeah it
sounds like they're just talking it
seems like they're having fun in the
studio and they're having fun when they
record yeah it doesn't seem like and I'm
probably wrong they're probably like
what the hell's wrong with you people
it doesn't seem like they're going in it
for a job it seems like you're just kind
of having fun doing it and that's just
me because I've heard some other voice
acting by some other people and it's
just like you hear that stress in their
voice like yes I'm doing another voice
now can we move on please I yeah I don't
know I you know I would if I was a guess
I'd say that they probably would like
these roles because it's not just you
know the Ice King acts goofy and stuff
it's that
he is this incredibly complex character
and the show allows them to go any
direction that they want pretty much
even Jake you know can have kind of some
emotional episodes we really know Jake
as a father it's like you know in a tree
being you know a very caring loving
father I mean it's a you never would
expect Jake to be like that from like
the first season or something yeah you
know and it's if the show allows enough
space and I'm not enough creativity to
go there yeah so uh if I guess I would
say they probably liked it but you never
know there might be billing just like
you know yeah it's just a job yeah but
but yeah boy you said is the most
important it sounds like yeah it sounds
like a bunch of friends get together and
record this stuff and like I'm just I
guess I'm picturing in my head and I
know that's done all different ways
everyone gets together or there's
individuals or whatever I'm just
picturing them like at a table read with
mics and that's how they're doing this
like they're delivering their lines and
after like a line or two someone starts
laughing and it's just like that's kind
of what I'm picturing in my head it's
like the cast just kind of gets together
it has a good time
then again they can all hate each other
and all bein in individual walls here
cuz we don't like dealing with each
other yeah they're they're hidden very
well yes true that's why I want to go in
for a kiss I'm like then that's about as
far as I can get restraining orders
there bitch I'm pretty sure you're
actually violating your restraining
order no actually ever we're straining
order against you I actually have a
restraining order against the bunny so I
bet yeah you probably should you can
leave too
that's disturbing I finally get to be
the last one standing